[Music]
solomon and son uh very funny so you
have a diverse cast a lot of ethnic
groups a lot of countries a lot of
nations represented in this throughout
the show who's not represented the one
group of people i didn't put in was the
brits because the brits i i'm just tired
of them coming over to our country on
our television shows letting us know how
crap you are gordon ramsay you can't
cook simon cowell you can't sing super
nanny can't take care of the kids it's
like look you bastards are from an
island the size of louisiana where the
sun never shines right there you know
god doesn't like you
you've been chewing rocks for centuries
your teeth messed up you like soccer no
black soccer your food's bland you can't
own a gun you worship a fake monarchy
that has no real power in the world and
you bastards haven't done jack squad
since pour some sugar on me so stay on
your decrepit little crappy island
this is america
we got cheese in our pizza crust
we got cupcake wars
america
we're never gonna die we're never gonna
die we're never gonna die
you guys supposed to we're never gonna
die
no one wants to go along with we're
never gonna die
we're never gonna die
[Applause]
that's what gets you horny